salut aujourd'hui on est jeudi vous le
savez maintenant le jeudi je vous parle
un peu de ce que j'ai envie ça n'a pas
forcément un lien direct avec le
mentalisme mais en fait on retrouve
toujours un petit peu l'idée la semaine
dernière je vous ai parlé de deux jeux
que j'aimais beaucoup cette semaine
reste dans le même état d'esprit je vais
vous parler de deux livres de livres qui
m'ont beaucoup plu encore une fois je
précise c'est pas du placement de
produits ce sont vraiment des livres qui
m'ont interpellé je les ai achetés je
les ai lu le premier c'est le
dictionnaire de l'impossible de didier
van je ne n'arrive pas à savoir comment
on prononce le nom didier voilà
politique y est effectivement c'est
monté comme un dictionnaire c'est à dire
que tout est dans l'ordre alphabétique
tous les thèmes et il prend des
expériences soient scientifiques soient
non rationnel et il en parle en fait il
raconte ce qui s'est passé à chaque fois
ça peut aller d'histoire qui ont été
racontées à l'heure après on valide on
valide pas sur la combustion humaine la
combustion spontanée comme sur des
choses qui ont été validés avec de vrais
protocole scientifique qui visait à voir
si les poussins avait des pouvoirs psy
vous n'entendrez plus jamais pioupious
de la même manière pour chacune des
situations qui relate il ya les sources
évidemment et puis elles prennent à
chaque fois entre deux et dix pages donc
ça se lit rapidement ça peut se faire
dans les transports on peut dire un ou
deux juste par jour je vous avoue que je
les dévorer voilà c'est le dictionnaire
de l'impossible du coup ça fait quelque
chose d'assez léger à lire sur des
sujets qui sont plus passionnants les
uns que les autres et puis après on peut
aller s'amuser à fouiller sur le net
c'est ce que j'ai fait moi et j'ai
appris pas mal de choses en fait c'est
surtout l'histoire des poussins en fête
qui attire et les robots par leurs
pensées cas c'est assez étrange assez
marrante pour vous dire rapidement le
protocole en fait il y avait il y avait
un robot que les poussins prenez pour
leurs mères puisque depuis la naissance
il l'avait et le robot avait des
mouvements aléatoires de programmer et
on sait que les poussins qui piaillaient
devant la vitre essayer d'attirer le
robot permet le robot n'a pas de sens
par rapport à ça c'était complètement
aléatoire et pourtant mathématiquement
ils ont battu le hasard sur le fait que
le robot se rapproche toujours des
poussins soit compte pas la suite parce
que c'est très intéressant et je vous
laisserai le découvrir au regard des
mêmes sujets sur internet l'histoire des
poussins qu'un robot on trouve des
sources et le deuxième c'est un livre
que j'ai lu très récemment c'est petite
expérience extra sensorielle de richard
whitman sauzée diction du nom de cette
audition que
et c'est pas non plus alors là c'est
très intéressant parce que déjà ses
écrits d'une manière très fun c'est très
rigolo à lire l'anglais c'est vraiment
un ton léger quasiment ristic et il
prend des thèmes comme le contrôle
mental parler avec les morts
sortir de son corps à chaque fois ça se
décompose de la manière suivante il va
parler d'histoire qui sont célèbres ou
pas mais qui ont été racontées dans des
livres sur des phénomènes comme ça
étrange et paranormaux et ensuite il y
apporte un point de vue scientifique
donc les contre arguments scientifiques
mais ya pas de parti pris 1 c'est à dire
que il détruit pas les croyances des
gens si vous avez des croyances dans des
domaines il est pas là pour les détruire
mais il apporte aussi les deux regards
en fait le regard extrasensorielles le
regard scientifique est dedans c'est ça
qui m'a beaucoup plu il propose des
expériences des choses assez ludique que
vous pouvez faire vous même pour vivre
les sensations de ces expériences
extrasensorielles il ya par exemple deux
expériences pour vivre des sensations de
sortie hors du corps de décorporation
donc où vous aller tromper votre esprit
en fait c'est tout un procédé qui permet
de tromper son esprit est de faire
croire à sa tête qu'on est ailleurs
c'est à chaque fois très facile à faire
il y en a une il faut juste une
serviette et un livret l'autre il faut
deux miroirs
c'était assez étrange de voir à quel
point on pouvait le tromper aussi dans
sa perception de l'espace en fait de
faire croire à notre esprit que notre
corps c'est celui qu'on voit devant nous
ça parle aussi de magicien ça parle de
mentalist ça parle de psychologie sont
vraies angle cacher c'est les
incroyables pouvoirs quand notre cerveau
en fait et comment on s'auto trompe
aussi parfois nous même et peut-être que
c'est pour ça que des fois on a des
croyances un peu particulière ou pas
encore une fois y'a pas de parti pris le
traitement est super fun et super rigolo
voilà c'est la vidéo du jeudi avait un
petit peu plus rapide allez un petit peu
plus fun la semaine prochaine vous
parlerai pas de choses que j'ai vues
lues
pas d'objets en tous cas mais d'un autre
sujet probablement en rapport avec les
mathématiques juste des trucs un petit
peu ouf on sait pas toujours si cette
vidéo vous a plu n'oubliez pas de la
partager abonnez-vous à la chaîne c'est
très important vous pouvez aussi venir
me voir sur les hallucinations
collectives que vous êtes en train de
voir actuellement ou samedi soir samedi
soir je serai dans le sud
je serai à la valette du var en
spectacle vous pouvez réserver je crois
qu'il reste encore quelques places
objectif de 1500 abonnés à 2500 abonnés
je fais un live où vous serez en direct
avec moi on pourra discuter faire des
trucs de mentalisme ensemble d'ici là
rendez vous demain à 17h sur cette
chaîne youtube pour le prochain mentale
vlog ciao